Apple try to buy Stargate Star Trek
everything sci-fi
could it even be remotely true welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
for a while now Apple TV has been trying
to get a big sci-fi franchise for Apple
TV plus they have the foundation series
which is bloody brilliant they have The
Silo series that starts May 5th which
has some serious heavyweight actors in
it
Will Patton Rebecca Ferguson Tim Robbins
this again is a big sci-fi project
and I've been hearing rumors for a long
time though that they're trying to get
their claws into other big already
existing franchises now they have
actually already ordered things like a
Speed Racer TV series
I actually think that would be quite
cool I I hope they don't quite go the
full Camp mode they did for the um movie
a few years ago but it could actually be
a lot of fun I've told you before that
they've been inquiring and want to get
their hands on the expanse and would
love to buy the TV rights from Amazon
and in about a year's time when Amazon's
current option for the expanse ends it's
very possible we may get to see a couple
of movies a series or something
but I'm hearing rumors as well that
they've been inquiring about big
existing franchises now the first time I
heard that they actually were interested
in doing a Star Trek series I was
initially a little skeptical but
actually if you think about it it's what
Paramount has been doing for the last
bloody decade all of the new track
pretty much all of it has been done in
cooperation with somebody else Picard
was done in cooperation with Amazon the
first couple of seasons of Discovery
were done in cooperation with Netflix
now it's been done more Paramount based
on the last few years but Paramount does
have large debts and maybe they don't
want all of the Star Trek series to
actually be on one place because you
know that saturates the market I'm
absolutely certain Paramount wouldn't
mind an injection of cash for one or two
series to maybe be done in cooperation
with apple that any new series would
appear on parent first and then maybe on
the next day it would appear on Apple
internationally who knows
but I've also heard rumors recently that
had me a little bit surprised and a bit
confused is that apparently Apple have
inquired also about Stargate they would
love to take on some part of a wider
franchise that I spoke about in the
previous video now this is firmly in the
rumor category and apparently this was
raised in a meeting between Apple and
Amazon Executives as nothing more than a
would you we might how much would it
cost we don't know sort of way it was no
formal negotiation and it really was
just a conversation
but it's a conversation that might make
sense now in the previous video I talked
about there were big plans for Stargate
they want to really rival Star Trek with
the Stargate program that they're
setting up they're even doing a
cinematic movie apparently
so
big plans and the Stargate Universe is
massive
so what I'm hearing is that the
conversation wasn't that any new
Stargate series like a main series like
the Prime series would go on MGM plus
and Amazon Prime
but there could be sort of like an
offshoot series something that
complements the series that could
potentially appear on Apple
now I actually don't hate this idea in
some ways because if it meant that
another company came in and bought a
television show
we'd get more Stargate
there's only so much money Amazon are
going to spend on it themselves
thingy partners now I've told you before
that they're looking at say maybe Sony
or something like that as a production
partner but that wouldn't actually give
them a lot of money per se because Sony
don't own their own streaming service
so but something like Apple
where they would potentially just be a
customer well they would say we would
love to commission a Stargate series on
the Jaffa Nation off top of my head
that would give us more Stargate and
actually I don't hate that idea but why
would Apple do this projects like
foundation and Silo actually even though
they're based on novels they're original
projects they're not part of a wider
franchise
well Apple are cash Rich they have the
money to do this but what they want is
they want that golden ticket franchise a
TV show that will actually bring people
across now Silo is a big budget TV show
and people will want to watch it but the
chances are it's not going to actually
attract many new subscribers there
aren't going to be people that are going
to actually actively go out of their way
to get apple to watch it if they've got
it already they probably will watch it
and probably love it
Ted lasso is one of those shows that
people have actually gone out of their
way to get Apple TV to watch I know
because I did a big TV show based around
the universe of Star Trek or Stargate or
something similar would do that and
there's a big rumor that it's very
possible that Babylon 5 will actually
end up on Apple TV plus because Apple
are willing to pay for it Warner
Brothers are quite happy to let them
it's the Sci-Fi fans in the next decade
you might need to get Apple TV plus and
I know a lot of you aren't very happy
about that idea at the end of the day
right now Apple TV plus are the only
streaming service that are cash Rich
they have the money to spend and they
desperately want a tentpole franchise
these existing franchises like Star Trek
Stargate and so on are kind of
considered safe bets that's why the
studios are bringing bringing them back
it's why they brought Star Trek back
it's why TV studios make so many reboots
remakes and reimaginings in the first
place because these projects come with a
ready-made audience and that's what
Apple are desperate for that ready-made
audience that will follow the TV show to
their streaming service guys what do you
think about this I know there's a lot of
you out there that really don't like
apple as a company and on moral grounds
you wouldn't get this streaming service
but what do you think about the idea of
like a side project of Stargate being
purchased by Apple still produced by MGM
but paid for by Apple
more Stargate equals more happiness
right
again for the concert tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
and you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where for a small fee
that supports a channel each month you
get to see most of our new videos first
and you get to see them without the
adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]